balancing chemical equations is one of
those concepts in chemistry that often
confuses people but i think if we will
see that if we work if we work through
this carefully and methodically and we
also appreciate the art of balancing
chemical equations that is actually not
too bad so first of all what is a
chemical equation well this is a
chemical equation right over here it's
describing a reaction so if i take an
atom of aluminum and i add it to a
dioxygen molecule so a molecule that has
two oxygens with it
with under the appropriate conditions
they will react to form aluminum oxide
and the aluminum oxide molecule has two
aluminum atoms and three oxygen atoms
and so you might say okay well what's
the balancing business all about i have
a chemical reaction what do i have to
balance
well if you look carefully you might
notice that you don't have the same
number of each atom on both sides so for
example right over here on the left hand
side how many aluminums do we have well
on the left hand side we have one
aluminum how many do we have on the
right hand side well on the right hand
side we have two aluminums and so
aluminum just can't appear out of thin
air by virtue of some magical reaction
you have to have the same amount of
aluminums on both sides and the same
thing is true for the oxygens over here
on the left hand side we have two
oxygens
they form one dioxygen molecule but that
has two oxygen atoms and then over here
in the aluminum oxide molecule we have
three
we have three oxygen atoms so once again
some we can't just have a miraculously
an oxygen atom appear for out of out of
nowhere so we have to balance the number
of aluminums on both sides this number
and this number should be the same and
we have to balance the number of oxygens
this number and that number should be
the same so how do we do that
well one thing might be to say okay if
i've got two aluminums here and i have
one aluminum here well why don't i just
double the number of aluminums right
over here so i can just write a 2 in
front of it so now this has two
aluminums so i no longer have one
aluminum here i now have two aluminums
and so it looks like the aluminums are
balanced and they are indeed balanced
but still we have an issue with the
oxygens
over here i have two oxygens over here i
have three oxygens
so one thing that you might say is okay
well how do i go from two to three i
could multiply by one and a half so i
could multiply
by
1.5 and if i multiply 1.5 times 2 well
that's going to be 3.
so now i have 3 oxygen atoms on this
side and 3 oxygen atoms on this side
but the convention is is that we don't
like writing one and a half molecules we
don't like having this notion of a half
molecule which is kind of this bizarre
notion we want whole number of molecules
so what can we do
well you can imagine this makes it very
similar to what you did in algebra an
algebraic equation is we just can
multiply both sides by the same number
that gets rid of having this fraction or
this decimal here so if we multiplied
both sides by 2 we're going to do that
this is going to be a 4 this is going to
be a 3 this is going to be a 2 right
over here so let me do that let me
multiply both sides by 2. so instead of
2 aluminum atoms let me have 4 aluminum
actually let me just write the chemical
equation first in the form that it was
before so i had aluminum
plus
dioxygen
a molecule of two oxygens
yielding in the reaction these are the
reactants this is the product
aluminum
aluminum
aluminum oxide so what i'm saying here
is to get rid of this 1.5 to turn it
into a whole number let's multiply all
of these
all of the number of molecules by 2. and
here there's implicitly
there's implicitly a one let me do this
in a different color
there is implicitly a one right over
here so let's multiply all these by two
so two times two is
do that same color
two times
two
is four
that's not the same color
two times two
is four one point five times two is
three and then one times two
1 times 2 is 2. and now you can verify
how many aluminums do we have on each
side well i have 4 aluminum atoms on the
left hand side and how many do i have on
the right hand side i have 4 aluminum
atoms how many oxygens do i have on the
left hand side
i have
three
molecules of dioxygen each molecule has
two oxygen atoms so i have six oxygens
on the left and i have two times three
oxygens on the right or i have six
oxygens so my chemical equation is now
balanced